on behalf of the Academy congratulations
to all the nominees and Oscar winners
you are part of a community that spans
its century not just a Hollywood
community or an American community but a
global one filled with storytellers
domestic and international one that is
becoming more inclusive and diverse with
each passing day I am proud to be part
of the evolution of this artform and to
see all the new faces among this year's
nominees tonight it's proof that art has
no borders art has no single language
and art does not belong to a single
faith for the power of art is that it
transcends all these things and as a
result all creative artists around the
world are connected by an unbreakable
bond that is powerful and permanent each
of you just as each of you being honored
tonight is linked together by a bond the
movies we love the ones that truly
matter regardless of country of origin
all speak to the human condition and the
values sorrows joys and passions that we
all share that is the music excuse me
that is the magic of the movies and that
is what we celebrate tonight
[Applause]